this is the world that you know
the world as it was at the end of the
20th century
it exists now only as part of a neural
interactive simulation
that we call the matrix
you've been living in a dream world neo
this is the world
as it exists today
[Music]
welcome
to the desert
of the real
the matrix one of the most influential
movie franchises ever created i
personally love the movies for many
reasons mainly due to the fact that they
constitute an unparalleled synthesis of
sci-fi action and engrossing narrative
but also due to the interesting
philosophies echoed throughout the
movies the wachowskis have managed to
bring together ideas from different
philosophers and psychologists and
create an extraordinary work of art we
seem as enthralled now by their meaning
as ever and they continue to be
sprinkled liberally across popular
culture this video is my attempt to
reveal these ideas and give to the
movies the obvious credit they deserve
this is your last chance
after this there is no turning back
you take the blue pill
the story ends
you wake up in your bed and believe
whatever you want to believe
you take the red pill you stay in
wonderland
and i show you how deep the rabbit hole
goes
remember
all i'm offering is the truth nothing
more
the predominant idea of the movies is
obviously that of the truth the red pill
and the blue pill symbolize truth and
ignorance respectively this idea derives
from the famous allegory of the cave
that can be found in plato's republic in
the allegory some people are imprisoned
inside a cave and the only thing they
can see is shadows projected in the
walls in front of them at some point one
prisoner somehow escapes and gains
access to the outer world which
symbolizes the absolute truth which is
quite abstract but in short one can
define this truth as the truth
disengaged from illusions delusions
propaganda lies and absurdities in the
matrix the truth is that the machines
are using the humans as energy source
and have created the matrix to keep them
occupied while they are in pods acting
as human batteries our fight to discover
the truth about everything is an
omnipresent fight in the matrix this
fight is represented in the fight
against the machines but also in the
fight to deny the comfort of the matrix
and accept a reality that is more
difficult but also more real so to speak
[Music]
no
[Music]
[Music]
how
he is the one
[Music]
the notion of the one alludes to the
idea of the messiah which is prevalent
in most popular religions neo is pure
determined smart capable and willing to
risk his life to save humanity he
represents the perfect messiah archetype
people can't operate without guidance
and without archetypes it is a necessity
nested deep in our social fabric without
figures to guide us represent us and
motivate us we feel lost and
disorganized neo is the savior people
need in order to move forward and master
the car as required to fight against the
machines
i know you can hear me
i'm not letting go
i can't
i love you too damn
[Music]
[Music]
love is the ultimate feeling and this is
highlighted throughout the movies with
the relationship between neo and trinity
they fell in love with each other and
they would do anything to protect each
other in matrix resurrections this love
goes one step further and it becomes an
us against the world theme neo and
trinity are not just lovers anymore they
are partners in crime but their romantic
relationship is not the only one that
stands out mero vengeance love with
persephone is also special it symbolizes
the declining nature of modern romantic
relationships and how nostalgia can lead
to revenge and eventually destroy a
relationship
i am so sick and tired of his [ __ ]
on and on
pompous prick
a long time ago when we first came here
it was so different
he was so different
he was like you
[Music]
when neo manages to maintain his powers
in the real world he essentially manages
to transcend his self i have said before
that self transcendence is the answer to
every question you might seek that is
connected to your search for inner
purpose and balance self-transcendence
is the core vision every human ought to
have in order to explain his or her role
in this world whether this is manifested
via a religious approach a spiritual
approach or a materialist approach is
not of importance self-transcendence is
the end goal for humanity in the movie
this is the prevailing idea neo
transcends himself and becomes a
superhuman outside the matrix i guess
this is achieved through singularity so
the directors chose to express that
through a materialist approach and urge
us to become more sanguine about the
future connection between humanity and
the machines
hello neil
who are you
i am the architect
i created the matrix
i've been waiting for you
you have many questions and though the
process has altered your consciousness
you remain irrevocably human there goes
some of my answers you will understand
and some of them you will not
concurrently while your first question
may be the most pertinent
you may or may not realize it is also
the most irrelevant
why am i here
your life is the sum of a remainder of
an unbalanced equation inherent to the
programming of the matrix you are the
eventuality of an anomaly which despite
my sincerest efforts i have been unable
to eliminate from what is otherwise a
harmony
of mathematical precision
this is undoubtedly my favorite scene
from the movie the architect is a
program framed as the creator of the
matrix the machines made him look
extremely intelligent and eloquent so he
can be perceived as the most
sophisticated virtual representation of
the entire machine mainframe as he
explains the current matrix reality is
the sixth iteration meaning that the
matrix gets reloaded every time the neo
anomaly attempts to liberate humans this
is an allusion to nietzsche's concept of
the eternal recurrence one of the most
discussed appearances of eternal
recurrence in nietzsche's work is
section 341 in the gay science the
greatest weight what if some day or
night a demon were to steal after you
into your loneliest loneliness and say
to you this life as you now live it and
have lived it
you will have to live once more and
innumerable times more and there will be
nothing new in it but every pain and
every joy and every thought and sigh and
everything unaderably small or great in
your life will have to return to you all
in the same succession and sequence
would you not throw yourself down and
gnash your teeth and curse the demon who
spoke thus or have you once experienced
the tremendous moment when you would
have answered him you're a god and never
have i heard anything more divine we're
trapped in a reality where every
perceptual pattern repeats itself
perpetually this sisyphean concept is
haunting our lives and we're trapped in
a lucid dream inundated by repetitions
and deja vus the matrix reminds us that
in the most eloquent way possible
it is known that the wachowskis asked
the actors to read
jean-botriya's book simulacra and
simulation published in 1983. a
simulacrum latin for likeness semblance
is a representation or imitation of a
person or thing in the book botreja uses
the term as a way of critiquing
contemporary culture and the way we
perceive what is real he writes we will
live in this world which for us has all
the disquieting strangeness of the
desert and of the simulacrum with all
the veracity of living phantoms of
wandering and simulating animals that
capital that the death of the capital
has made us because the desert of cities
is equal to the desert of sand the
jungle of science is equal to that of
the forests the vertigo of simulacra is
equal to that of nature only the
vertiginous seduction of a dying system
remains in which work betters work in
which value based value a goodreads
reader explains his work nicely
he wants to make it clear that our world
itself is a simulacrum that all of the
institutions we hold as the foundations
of our understanding of how the world
works are in essence not real as he says
early in the book it is dangerous to
unmask images since they dissimulate the
fact that there is nothing behind them
simulacra and simulation is a very
difficult but deep read sometimes
botriya uses a more complex language
than needed but his points can be quite
eye opening if read carefully an
interesting fact is that botriya didn't
really enjoy the matrix in an interview
with the french magus in le nouvelle
observator he says what is notable about
matrix reloaded is the absence of a
glimmer of irony that would allow
viewers to turn this gigantic special
effects on its head moreover this is
what makes the film an instructive
symptom and the actual fetish of this
universe of technologies of the screen
in which there's no longer a distinction
between the real and the imaginary the
matrix is considered to be an
extravagant object at once candid and
perverse
where there is neither a here nor there
basically it's a dissemination on a
world scale is complicit with the film
itself on this point it is worth
recalling marshall mcluhan the medium is
the message the message of the matrix is
its own diffusion by an uncontrollable
and proliferating contamination what he
means is that the matrix is presented as
a critique of the system which
ironically massively promoted and that
the directors never did their own
self-critique within the movies
you are here because you were sent here
you were told to come here and then you
obeyed
it is of course the way of all things
you see there is only one constant
one universal it is the only real toss
causality
action
reaction
cause
and effect
everything begins with choice no wrong
choice is an illusion created between
those with power
and those without
free will couldn't be left out of the
matrix narrative
human behavior and the way we react to
external manipulation render us more or
less incapable of exercising the idea of
free will in the movies the machines are
taking advantage of this and foster
humans in nearly perfect reality so they
can exploit them as an energy source
whether free will exists or not is
difficult to corroborate neo constitutes
an anomaly in the matrix system and
through his anomalous nature we become
more aware of the choices we can make as
humans we see in neo everything we are
but also everything we can become
we struggle we hate we love we enjoy we
resist we fight back every behavior we
change is like an anomaly for the system
some we enjoy some we don't but at least
everything we do is our choice
maybe
hey guys hope you enjoyed today's video
if you did make sure to like subscribe
turn on notifications and comment below
something cool please so that more
people can discover it
if you want to watch more videos from my
channel check out this one and this one
take care see you soon adrian out
you